my name's Logan I may be able to help
you find someone I know how special you
are
I come with you I'm coming from blood
are you ready no law to do what you need
to do no code of conduct that's of death
you want to sue me so they did to me
what I am it can't be done done
you're different now I give heart yeah a
lot of people have tried to kill me and
I'm still here
you have a struggler the long way enough
right now of feeling unbelievable
gratitude that this pot happened to come
into my life what you have with
Wolverine in his backstory and an actor
of the power of Hugh Jackman playing him
as a unique among other superhero films
Wolverine and Hugh Jackman cannot Maori
separates the man and the role have
merged
he's found a way to connect a deep part
of himself to this character
ladies and gentlemen Hugh Jackman this
is gonna be my last time opening on the
claws one last time
this is what the life looks like feel it
till halftime what's so wonderful about
you is that he's hungry to go deeper and
darker than he's ever been before
because this is Hugh's last movie as
this character I wanted to make sure not
that it's his last movie but that is his
best
and cut we got it it's a really surreal
day I've got my 16 year old in the
trailer who was not even born when I
started playing this no movie has meant
more to me than this movie when the
bottom I heart thank you so much for
helping us realize this turn I am
grateful to the fence in a big way and I
consider it a great great privilege to
have had the chance to play as character
[Music]
you
[Music]
you